die flagge der taliban in kunduz symbol
für die jüngste dramatische entwicklung
die islamisten ziehen in afghanistans
städte ein zerstören häuser töten
zivilisten immer mehr menschen fliehen
es sind vor allem handy aufnahmen die
das dokumentieren auch für das zdf wird
es immer schwieriger im land zu drehen
masar i scharif wie kundus eine der
städte in denen die bundeswehr im
einsatz war vertraute namen
ein kollege dreht für uns in einem der
provisorischen zeltlager familien die
vor den taliban geflohen sind kinder die
von ihren eltern in sicherheit gebracht
wurden
rossana ist alleine mit ihren sechs
kindern hier wie man riecht bei den
kämpfen ums leben gekommen
die taliban sind gekommen es gab schwere
kämpfe unser haus wurde zerstört es ist
abgewandt ich habe meine kinder genommen
und bin gefroren
wir haben nicht
wohin das fragen sich in diesen tagen
millionen afghanen
der besten hinterlässt ein land das
immer mehr im chaos zu versinken droht
die bevölkerung dem terror der taliban
ausgeliefert
[Musik]
vor sechs wochen waren wir selbst noch
in masar i scharif trafen dort
nadschibullah anssari der familienvater
hat als übersetzer für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet einer von denen die auf den
todeslisten der taliban stehen von ihrer
angst und ihren hoffnungen erzielten die
anzahl ist damals noch in ihrem
wohnzimmer
ich kann hier nicht arbeiten ich kann
nicht in die stadt gehen
ich muss das land verlassen ich möchte
dass die deutschen uns an einen sicheren
ort bringen
beim abschied habe ich das bedrückende
gefühl die familie fühlt sich von
deutschland im stich gelassen sie wissen
nicht einmal wo sie visa beantragen
können mittlerweile kann auch unser team
nur noch in kabul filmen reisen ins land
sind zu gefährlich
in der hauptstadt treffen wir familie
ansari wieder sie sind aus masar i
scharif geflohen seit fast einem monat
leben sie in einem safe aus einem
gesicherten haus dass bundeswehrsoldaten
privat für afghanische ortskräfte
eingerichtet haben als erster deutscher
fernsehsender darf das zdf hier drehen
der ort soll geheim bleiben
wir mussten aufstehen denn überall wo
die taliban die macht übernommen haben
brennen sie häuser nieder und löschen
der ganze familien aus
angola und seine frau haben alles
aufgegeben wie alle 15 familien die hier
schutz finden und sie alle fragen sich
wie soll es jetzt weitergehen
jeden moment unseres lebens verbringen
wir in angst wir rechnen jederzeit mit
einem angriff unser leben ist
unerträglich geworden
ob deutschland ihnen asyl gewährt das
wissen sie nicht nur eins wenn die
taliban kabul einnehmen sind sie auch
hier nicht mehr sicher
auch die hauptstadt noch unter kontrolle
der regierung erlebt dramatische tage so
viele afghanen und afghaninnen die wir
in den letzten wochen getroffen haben
sitzen jetzt auf gepackten koffern mit
jedem tag sinkt die hoffnung dass die
freiheiten der letzten 20 jahre erhalten
bleiben
jascha dopp ist eine der afghanischen
frauen die für ein weltoffenes modernes
land eintreten wir haben uns schon
mehrfach getroffen zuletzt in ihrer
boutique im zentrum von kabul
die 26 jährige hat ihr eigenes modelabel
kreiert geschäftsfrau aber auch
influenza
selbstbewusst und mutig doch auch vor
sechs wochen schon erzählte er von der
wachsenden unsicherheit von drohungen
die auch sie erhielt
leute wie ich versuchen anderen zu
zeigen dass afghanen afghanische frauen
auch arbeiten können auch ihre freiheit
haben können
ich liebe mein land und ich kann mir nur
vorstellen zu gehen wenn die situation
wirklich schlecht wird
die hoffnung vieler afghanen istanbul
die türkei ist in diesen tagen ziel für
so viele die sich und ihre familien in
sicherheit bringen wollen schon jetzt
leben schätzungen zufolge mehr als
500.000 afghanen hier doch inzwischen
stellt die türkei keine visa mehr aus
dass es noch rechtzeitig geschafft ein
visum zu bekommen aber ob sie hier
bleiben kann das weiß sie nicht dass es
so schnell gehen würde dass sie die
flucht ergreifen musste sie kann es
selbst noch nicht fassen
wir haben keine wahl
besonders für frauen wir uns die
arbeiten ist es nicht sicher in
afghanistan zu bleiben
für taliban sind die frauen die keinen
schleier tragen die außerhalb des hauses
arbeiten unerträglich sie fällen keine
urteile sie haben keine gesetze sie
töten
mit ihren mitarbeitern in ihrer
schneidereien kabul hält die
geschäftsfrau jeden tag kontakt gibt
anweisungen für die neue kollektion es
muss weitergehen solange es noch möglich
ist
gibt es noch hoffnung
jetzt kommt es auf die menschen an auf
die regierung die müssen widerstand
leisten unser land verteidigen wir
können für unser land nur bilden
[Musik]
eine begegnung die das ganze ausmaß der
afghanischen tragödie zeigt wenn alle
die das land aufbauen und modernisieren
wollten es jetzt verlassen was bleibt
dann noch von afghanistan